do you find because you've been through
so much man do you find yourself
um
more calculated now in terms of just
like that I'm older
I learned you know what I mean you've
been through like I'll make the same
mistakes of course you feel me yeah that
I made
um
when I was 19. that was be that'd be
insane yeah
family I try to you know at least get
better every day you have to man you
feel me
um like look just think about it I got
suspended
twice for smoking weed so crazy it's
crazy probably cost me like 30 million
dollars if I think about it because of
the in it did it affected your next
deals because I was a free agent you had
a stigma oh this guy smokes weed he's a
he's a troublemaker which by the way now
we know it doesn't [ __ ] matter they
don't even test for weed in the NBA
it's crazy so yeah you feel me yeah now
I'm about to get paid for selling we for
selling dope they call it dope I hate
that word it's amazing you got your own
weed coming out you feel me yeah what's
the week on
is Odum cannabis is with flight path
and on the first two strings it's just
gonna be uh cereal milk and gelato nice
got some dope package how would you guys
hide weed back in the day when you were
playing like would you know if you were
gonna get piss tested or was it random
yeah that's what I'm saying about the
youth [ __ ] right right like I know
that I'm getting tested
um
so you and you're still doing it
but you knew yeah
you were just kind of hoping
roulette with your with your career